Bonjour ! Comment allez-vous ?
Moi ça va extrêmement bien !
Les amis aujourd'hui je souhaite prendre ma revanche
Sur un jeu
Qui m'a profondément fait du mal !
*Glisse* NON !!
NON NON NON NON !
NON !
NAN !
*Pleure*
Mais aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'avoir un atout extraordinaire
Un génie a fait son apparition
Il m'a dit, "Lucas..."
"Je vais te donner un POUVOIR !"
"Dès que tu toqueras à la porte ici, quelqu'un viendra pour t'aider"
Et là j'me suis réveillé
Natsu avait pissé sur le tapis
Donc j'étais très content !
On est de nouveau sur ce maudit jeu
Avec ce PUTAIN de chaudron et ce marteau.
Vous connaissez très bien où j'en suis parce que j'en suis au TOUT DÉBUT DU JEU!!
J'ai fait que tomber
Du coup j'me retrouve au début du jeu
C'est incroyable ce qu'il se passe
C'qu'on va faire c'est que j'vais essayer tout seul d'y arriver,
Si je rage trop j'irai toquer à la porte
Et quelqu'un viendra m'aider
Parce que mec
Je n'en peux plus.
En plus j'ai perdu la main mec
ça me pète déjà les couilles
Ok...
*Glisse*
Putain de merde
C'est Incroya- Attends
NAN Mais mec
J'AI PERDU LA MAIN !
Mec, t'sais quoi, j'men bat les couilles
*TOC TOC*
*Laink entre* OHHHHHH
- Mec, assis-toi Laink, j'ai besoin de toi
Est-ce que tu as joué à ce jeu ?
- Non !
- PUTAIN !
- J'ai pas joué à ça mec !
Nan mais jai déjà vu le premier niveau t'es pas allé très loin excuse-moi
- Mec !
- Regarde !
- Quoi ? T'es allé plus loin toi ?
- Non en vrai je sais pas mec
Donc c'est bien, si j'ai bien compris, un mec dans un pot qui est tout nu
- C'est ça ! *rires*
C'est comme nous en soirée
- Ok...
- C'est bien ! C'est bien t'y es !
- Ah ! Ça m'énerve quand il fait ça ! Ça m'énerve quand il fait ça !
Ça va... hé !
Hop là !
Ok c'est bon
- Attention ! Là si tu mets un coup de main...
- Oh ça fait
- OH !
OHH !
- Attention attention !
Vas-y ! Là mainte-
AAAAAH !
- Vas-y j'appelle un youtubeur j'en ai marre ! Eh c'est terminé !
Tu sais ce que je vais faire ? Je vais rester là toute la vidéo
Et me foutre de la gueule de tous les gens qui vont passer !
*TOC TOC TOC*
- Oh ! Sofyan !
- On a un problème de marmite ?
*rires*
- Sofyan, Il faut vraiment que tu réussisses à passer ce putain de niveau
- Ça fait 15 ans que je fais de ça... de la pioche
En vrai, je me suis entraîné un peu. J'ai compris que la technique c'était ça :
Après...
OHHH !
*rires* OH LA LA LA !
Bon, vas-y, alors
- Essaie juste de passer le premier, Sofyan, et pour nous c'est une victoire
- Ouais, merci mec parce que...
*rires*
- Hop! Comme ça
Pffou...
- Hé ! Il va peut-être aller plus loin que toi !
- Il n'est pas hyper calme dans ses mouvements mais ça fonctionne !
- Et là attendez, là je fais comment là?
- Là tu le poses sur le rocher en fait
Vas-y, va vers la droite
- À droite
Voilà
- Et là, je suis baisé !
En fait c'est la sérénité et c'est toute la méditation en fait qui fait en sorte...
- Qu'il y a autour, qui permet de...
- Qui fait en sorte que....
PUTAIN !!!
*rires*
Sérénité
Oh! OOOH!
OH PUTAIN !
Ça marche!
Sérénité, méditation
Oh Dalaï-Lama ! Oh là !
*rires*
PUTAIN !
- Sofyan, s'il te plaît, appelle un mec fort,
parce que là, moi j'en peux plus, je te le dis.
Dis-le si c'est pas un tueur qui entre.
*rires*
- Eh merde, c'est le pire!
- On est foutu!
- Attendez, déjà : enfin un mec grand !
- Vas-y assieds-toi là, putain.
Raf' tu as un objectif
Baisse la tête
Tape sur la nuque
On est parti.
- Attends, juste un truc.
- Mais arrête de manger là bordel !
Putain on est en train de tourner, c'est incroyable!
- Eh mieux vaut avoir le plus nul dès le début.
- Oui c'est vrai.
Mais le problème c'est qu'on a eu les trois plus nuls dès le début.
- Et quel est son pro...
Il s'est coincé dans un pot ? Dans une marmite ?
- Eh on est pas là pour débattre sur son histoire.
- Alors...
- On va pas le juger, ok? C'est pas ça qu'on veut.
- On ne juge pas mais est-ce qu'il a une pension d'invalidité ?
au quel cas...
- On va pas juger l'état non plus!
Ooooooh !!!!
- Mais pourquoi il y a une pagaie là ? Pourquoi il y a une rame ?
- Mais je sais pas, mec !
- Mais j'ai envie de savoir
Bon déjà là...
- ARRÊTE DE MANGER !
J'en ai marre, tu arrêtes de manger!
Après l'effort le réconfort
-Regarde, regarde, je vais la pécho
OOHH !
En fait j'aimerai savoir comment il s'est retrouvé là dedans...
C'est un homme tronc
-Pendant que tu essaies je vais te raconter son histoire
-Ok..
-C'est un mec qui sortait de la douche
Y avait une fuite d'eau dans la salle de bain du mec
La femme elle a mis un chaudron en dessous la fuite d'eau
..Ok ?
Pour pas que y ait un dégât des eaux sur son sol
Mcfly on sais que tu n’es pas un youtuber de jeu vidéos
On pense que tu vas y arriver
Juste un truc, il ne Sufi pas de respirer fort
Mcfly: le truc en métal il n’es pas bien Mis sur le truc
Mcfly : Voilà le taper, un peu, attendez !
Un petit peu de bricolage ne fait pas de mal
Squeezie : Putain
McFly : Je pars en dab
McFly : OOOOOH
Mcfly : Ne soit pas négatif à ce point ! Squeezie : Moi j'ai une mi..
Squeezie : Non mais McFly ! Moi j'ai une mission aujourd'hui : il faut que j'arrive à aller au bout de ce jeu
On m'a envoyé des gens pour m'aider mais là ce qu'il se passe c'est
pas ça ok !
McFly : Ok on y va regarde !
Squeezie : Allez, ça dégage !
Appelle le suivant stp
*rire*
Martin : Ca va les gars, vous allez bien ?
Squeezie : T'es youtubeur ? T'es ?
Martin : Ouai euh ouai
Squeezie : Tu t'appelles comment ?
Martin : Je m'appelle Martin
Squeezie : C'est pour ça que t'as un M avec toi toujours, mais tu peux t'asseoir Martin
Squeezie : Martin c'est le mec inconnu ! Martin tu as
10s pour nous impressionner c'est parti !
Squeezie : Allez ça dégage
merci Martin
Squeezie : c'est quoi ça ?
Mais vous êtes malades
C'est quoi le rapport
Tiens, tiens
Carlito : Oh attends j'ai un rébus
Vous dites rugby vous !
Maxenss : Mon pied, mon ami
Carlito : Ouais bravo
Mcfly : j'ai un rébus
Pied de chaise
Squezzie : attends donne moi ce pied pour voir
Putain mais c'est de la merde ce que tu as dit
Mcfly : Stop !
Maxenss : Eh, on peut dire il prend son pied
Squezzie : OOHH !!
Jiraya : Donc moi je doit aller le plus loin possible
Squezzie : tu dois aller le plus loin possible on compte sur toi. C'est parti
J’en vais manipuler
C’est la force des meilleurs
*Cyril* Tutuchhhu!
Dégage ...
*cyril* La seconde chance (x2)
La triforce
...
*squeezie* Cyril, tu es notre dernier espoir
Cyril: calme toi
Je suis heureux mais je sais que je vais tomber
Je tombe et emporte mon pote avec moi :'c Mais NOUS SOMMES CONTENTS
J'ai tout fait foiré mais c po grave
abonne toi ;)
je roule je roule, oh non je me suis fait mal aurevoir
Je suis Maxenss je suis génial ♥☻
SQUEEZIE PAYE MOI BATARD
LE JOUEUR FRANCAIS!!!
Je suis un génie
Personne ne me connait mais je suis rigolo
Tu es encore là? Je suis d'accord avec toi c'est une très bonne vidéo alors abonne toi!